لم يرق لمحبي الاشجار في مصر ازاله
الحدائق التي توسطت احياء القاهره والجيزه
لتوسيع الطرق واقامه الجسور لا يقفون ضد
فكره التطوير ولكنهم ببساطه يحبون الاشجار
التي يعود بعضها الى اجيال خلاد سهيله
ساوي صوت من هذه الاصوات طبعا مشروع هائل
بس في نفس الوقت ما ننساش الشجر الموجود
يعني ده كمان ما نعملوش وما نشيلش الشجر
عشان نعمل حاجات ثانيه عشان ده قديم يعني
دي نظريه ما فيش حاجه اسمها شجره قديمه
يعني ده حرام
في مكان اخر من المدينه المزدحمه يتعاون
الشباب الاحزاب مع الجمعيات والافراد في
زراعه اشجار مثمره بعد ما اطلق الرئيس
المصري مبادره لزراعه مئه مليون شجره
الدكتور احمد غريب صاحب مبادره اثمار يحلم
بان يذوق المواطنون ثمار اشجاره خلال عام
او اثنين على الاكثر في بعض الفئات بتبقى
غير قادره على شراء فواكه زراعه الاشجار
الفواكه في الشوارع ده بيبقى بيخلي اا
يعني نوع من انواع الرضا لدى المواطنين
العاديين ان هم يحصلوا على الفواكه
بطريقه لائقه وبطريقه همم كريمه قال بعض
انتقد هذه المبادره خوفا من تكالب بالناس
على قذف الفاكهه زراعه 100 مليون شجره لو
احنا كل مواطن حتى الطفل كده ليه شجره فمش
هيبقى فيه تكالب دوت او يبقى فيه العلاقات
ديه يعني
هذه المبادرات تستلزم التنسيق مع الاحياء
والمجالس المحليه لضمان الاستدامه اول
حاجه مصدر الميه عشان خاطر الزرع يبقى
مستمر معنا ويدينا الانتاج اللي احنا
عايزينه فلازم يتعاون مع اي احد في الحي
اللي هو فيه في كل اداره فيها موجود مدير
حدائق موجوده يبقى مسؤول عن الموضوع ده
الشجر لازم يتحط في اماكن معينه بحيث ان
هو لا يتعارض مع الطرق ولا يتعرض مع خطه
الدوله المستقبليه في التنميه عشان كده
احنا بنحاول نحط الاشجار بالتعاون مع
اداره التشجير او اداراه التشجير في
الاحياء المختلفه الاشجار والمثمره
ستحتاجه ايضا لعنايه فائقه لنهايه التسميد
والتهذيب حتى تعطي افضل انتاجيه بالغرض
الاجتماعيه والبيئيه من زراعتها تامر نصره
العربيه القاهره